le premier ministre la parole est à
madame valérie la croûte
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche un
incendie criminel a ravagé l'église
saint-louis à fontainebleau un hôtel du
16e siècle a été entièrement brûlées des
hosties consacrées jetée sur le sol
l'enfant jésus de la crèche volé un peu
plus tard c'est un autre incendie
probablement accidentelle qui a détruit
l'église de voeux ne les sablons avant
la chute mystérieuse d'une croix en
forêt de fontainebleau
ces actes inqualifiables ont suscité de
nombreuses réactions d'indignation à
fontainebleau et partout dans le pays
ils ont profondément choqué les membres
de la communauté catholique
déjà inquiets par la recrudescence
d'actes anti chrétiens en france ces
derniers mois
je veux leur exprimer toute ma
compassion et ma solidarité en visant le
coeur de la foi catholique
les criminels n'ont pas seulement
insulté la communauté des croyants ils
ont offensé la communauté nationale
toute entière car lorsqu'un culte et
profané lorsque des sépultures sont
dégradées ce sont la république et ses
valeurs qui sont piétinées après les
attentats de paris de telle profanation
contribue à entretenir un climat de peur
et de suspicion
quelle que soit leur motivation elles
doivent être condamné avec la plus
grande fermeté
je salue la venue du ministre de
l'intérieur hier soir à fontainebleau
mais regrette la réaction trop tardive
du gouvernement face à des événements si
grave dans le contexte actuel
nos concitoyens n'attendent pas
seulement de l'état du réconfort et du
soutien ils attendent des actes concrets
monsieur le premier ministre pouvez-vous
nous assurer que tout sera entrepris
pour retrouver les acteurs de ces actes
et que ceux ci seront sévèrement
sanctionnés pouvez-vous nous assurer que
la protection des lieux de culte sera
renforcée dans notre pays
merci merci madame la parole est à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur même la députée nous étions
hier soir ensemble
à fontainebleau avec les représentants
des forces de sécurité les élus et le
représentant du procureur de la
république vous insisté sur la nécessité
d'assurer la protection des lieux de
culte et je veux ici rendre hommage aux
dizaines de milliers de policiers et de
gendarmes qui depuis le mois de janvier
dernier par des gardes statiques et
dynamiques assure la protection de
l'ensemble des lieux de culte en france
et comme vous étiez avec moi hier soir à
fontainebleau vous avez entendu comme
moi hier soir à fontainebleau
lévesque et le prêtre de la paroisse de
saint louis remercier chaleureusement
l'état les forces de sécurité pour le
travail qui est fait depuis des mois et
notamment pour l'engagement des forces
de l'ordre au moment de noël engagement
qui a permis aux messes de se dérouler
dans un climat de sécurité absolue car
la laïcité c'est la possibilité de
croire et de ne pas croire et c'est
aussi la possibilité à ceux qui ont fait
le choix par l'exercice de leur libre
arbitre de leur religion de pouvoir la
pratiquer librement
il n'ya donc pas lieu madame la députée
je me réjouis que ça n'ait pas été le
cas hier soir au moment de ma visite de
faire de polémique sur ce sujet tous les
lieux de culte sont protégés ce sont
plus de 2000 église qui le sont en
permanence ce sont près de 800 mosquées
qu'ils le sont en permanence et un très
grand nombre
également deux synagogues parce que
l'état a une responsabilité particulière
qu'il assume par l'engagement des forces
de l'ordre sur et la protection de tous
les lieux de culte
vous indiquez que la réaction a été
tardive je rappelle que l'événement
s'est produit le matin qu'il a fallu
pour des raisons qui tiennent aux
particularités de l'anc est que nous
ayons des informations et j'ai
communiqué dès le dimanche et j'étais
hier sur place et nous étions ensemble
lorsque l'essentiel est en jeu
nous devons laisser les polémiques mer
c'est une erreur le ministre